in the lead up to the 2020 Academy
Awards set to air on Sunday February 9th
Adam Sandler was near the head of the
pack for Best Actor contenders for his
performances diamond district jeweler
and self-destructive gambling addict
Howard Ratner in the safty brothers
crime thriller uncut gems Sandler had
most everyone believing he'd land at
least a nomination for the coveted award
however when the list of 20/20 our
nominations rolled out Sandler's name
was nowhere to be found despite the fact
that viewers everywhere thought he'd be
a shoe-in now the New York Post has run
quotes from an anonymous Academy member
who commented on some of the actors who
didn't score Oscar nominations this year
dolomite is my name star Eddie Murphy
hustlers lead Jennifer Lopez The
Farewell actress aquafina and of course
Sandler the nameless actor revealed the
real reason why Adam Sandler was snubbed
and the answer isn't pretty let's not
forget Adam Sandler is a seriously funny
actor stay here stay as long as you can
God he split sides and films like happy
gilmore Billy Madison the waterboy the
wedding singer Big Daddy and more
gaining Fame as much more than a former
Saturday Night Live player in the 2000s
Sandler ventured into more dramatic
territory with Spanglish punch-drunk
love and funny people effectively
proving he wasn't a one-trick pony but
at a certain point Sandler's track
record grew spotty when he began signing
onto films that were well less than
spectacular he racked up Razzies
basically the ugly stepsister to the
merit-based award ceremonies for just go
with it
and Jack and Jill two of Sandler's worst
movies ever and tarnished his reputation
in the process it's only been in recent
years through his turns and films like
Netflix's the meyerwitz stories and now
uncut gems that Sandler has begun to
shed his king of bad movies moniker
sadly Oscars voters have a stronger
memory than the general public does the
reason why he didn't receive an Oscar
nomination according to the well-known
character actor and member of the
Academy is because people don't
associate the name
Adam Sandler with accolades as
prestigious as Academy Awards the source
claimed there are a lot of movies a lot
of performances per year for us to watch
unfortunately actors become brands
Sandler's brand doesn't scream Oscar
ouch during an appearance on the Howard
Stern Show and early December 2019
Sandler threatened revenge on the
movie-going masses if he didn't nab an
Academy Award for his performance in
uncut gems the actor warned that he
would take a role in an unbelievably bad
movie to make everyone regret not
nominating for and more importantly
awarding him with an Oscar Sandler said
if I don't get it I'm going to come back
and do one again that is so bad on
purpose just to make you all pay that's
how I get them he added that though it
would be a quote funny big thing for him
to receive an Oscar nomination he would
be there to win if it actually happened
we all know that it didn't and it seems
Sandler's plan for payback could still
be intact given that his filmography
isn't exactly packed wall-to-wall with
winners the actor doesn't have much to
lose if he does go through with making a
terrible film except the respect of the
Academy voting body in response to
Sandler's comments on the Howard Stern
Show one member allegedly complained
that the actor has in arrogance to him
and that his threat showed quote a lack
of respect for everyone's sake
hopefully Sandler sticks to more
substantial gigs and doesn't actually
make a total stinker to follow up on cut
gems he may not have been placed in the
running for Oscars gold following his
turn in the film but the fact that he
generated genuine buzz for a Best Actor
Award speaks volumes may Sandler's
future and ours feature more roles like
Howard Ratner and fewer like well check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff for coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]